es ist eine kleine macke tisch das ist
jetzt hier der fridolin oder und ich bin
schon teil des rohstoffbooms willkommen
dabei einmal video und zwar habe ich ja
vor
ich weiß es nicht es ist schon ein
halbes jahr her oder so da hab ich doch
video gemacht so beeindruckt man jeden
jungen und viele zuschauer sind ja also
weiblich und gucken dass sowas und das
video echt gut angekommen deswegen habe
ich mich auch warum machst du nicht
einfach mal zweiten teil wir fallen ein
paar mehr in sachen einen was so man
eventuell machen könnte und deswegen
gibt es das heute ach ja was ich bei der
recherche für die schüler auch aus
gefunden also es gibt auch viele dinge
wie man halt einen jungen nicht
beeindruckt und falls ihr bock habt dass
ich dazu mal wieder machen würde wird
glaube ich echt ganz amüsant anlass
einfach mal doch noch wunder oder
schreibt wendy kommentare irgendwie
sowas dann weiß ich bescheid und dann
gibt's das auch mal weil das wäre cool
auf jeden fall ja ich weiß ich habe
schon viel zu lange aber ich will
eigentlich gar nicht so lange japan und
deswegen geht es direkt los es gibt ja
heutzutage einfach so viele verschiedene
wieso niemand tragen kann ich meine
selbst als machen kannst du jede scheiße
tragen also man kann immer alles fragt
aber viele verfolgen also das was so
grad so ein bisschen ist und für frauen
gibt es ja auch diese frisuren da hat
man hier so einen ball auf dem kopf oder
da hat man zwei köpfe und sieht aus wie
pippi langstrumpf oder was wenn ich dann
gibt es auch noch so sein kann oder so
bisher so rüber und dann
hier noch blau gefärbt keine ahnung es
gibt ja relativ viel aber jungs die
finden das eigentlich alles scheiße wenn
du so eine zeitkarte hast oder so kannst
du gibst voll wenige das vielleicht
helfen oder so deswegen also macht immer
eure haare offen am besten weil das ist
halt das beste wenn ihr die irgendwie so
verknotet oder so dass ihr irgendwie ein
bisschen so unheimlich aus das das
richtige wort auf jeden fall sieht es
nicht so wenn die alten jungen waren
bald macht einfach eure haare offen dass
das beste er ja das wäre schon ein punkt
2 und zwar nicht hier wäre ihr kennt
doch bestimmt alle diese super
selbstbewussten mädchen die da so stimmt
wenn ihr so umlauf
funktioniert das nicht das geht nicht so
etwas jedoch oft das was ist denn los
mit euch das sieht einfach erstens
danach aus als hätte dir 0
selbstbewusstsein 21 scheiße aus und
drittens arterien 0 selbstbewusstsein ok
guck mal hier stehen meine videos auch
so und wenn ihr so einen jungen so
richtig gut beeindrucken wollte was
heißt beeindrucken aber das ist schon so
ein wichtiger ausschlaggebender punkt
dann geht nicht so ich bin wie schon
toll sondern habe hier zufällig in meine
sonnenbrille vom letzten urlaub
das ist der neueste schritt nein es war
immer schon steht aber so ist wirklich
besser also nicht so sondern das leben
ist schön
alexis cool ja was dann auch noch sehr
sollen so ein kleiner trick oder so ist
um halt so ein bisschen so was heißt
beeindruckt aber so aufmerksamkeit
erregen so und das süß sein empfinden
vom jungen halt wisst ihr was ich meine
das ist aber wirklich also damit auch
gar nichts schief gehen sonst habt ihr
verkackt ich brauche jetzt bräuchte
jetzt eine zweite person in dem einfach
mal diese schlangen hier das ist jetzt
also hier als ob sie es ist eine kleine
macke im fisch das ist jetzt hier der
fridolin oder so und ich bin stadtteil
also damit jetzt bei ihm ihr dieses volk
judt gedanke dass das dieser gedanke
entsteht können wir so einen trick
anwenden das es trägt aber das muss
wirklich die situation uns passen in dem
er den jungen so aus was ihnen an stellt
man also nicht jetzt so ja was machst du
in orten tschuldigung sondern so halt
weiß ich nicht er geht so die treppe
runter oder so und dann so was halt ne
und ihr wisst was ich meine das muss
wirklich passen und dann denkt er sich
sodann entschuldigt du dich so verloren
so entschuldigung und das ist immer gut
auch wenn es bisher sie scheiße anhört
aber das ist so und danke fridolin aber
du bist irgendwie blöd ich nochmal das
war jetzt vielleicht schlecht
dargestellt aber ihr wisst was ich damit
meine oder wenn nicht anschuldigung aber
wenn man halt als mädchen man stolpert
die ab und zu mal trends stolpert
reflexartig in den jungen die auch gut
findet und nicht in irgendeinen anderen
was auch very important ist ihr dürft
ich immer so als mädchen eigentlich
gehen ja fast alle mädchen auch mit
diesem mainstream ex leggins und sonne
scheint aber das ist halt nicht so gut
weil dann seid ihr halt genauso wie die
an
ich will jetzt nicht dass ihr mit blauer
hose orange im oberteil und mit
gummistiefeln kommt sondern halt ein
bisschen anders so cool traum so
vielleicht mit polio lasso und die hose
weil er manchmal somit lag ins comics
und so eine scheiße das kommt auch so
ein bisschen arrogant rüber manchmal ich
will es kein angreifen dabei ist so bei
jungs und deswegen kommt einfach mal mit
pulli oder jogginghose sogar ganz cool
das wäre wohl die checker so wie ich das
weiß nur spaß also
das nicht zu ernst ja wie gesagt halt
einfach mal so selbst wenn wir nur in
die schule geht ist auch scheißegal wir
mit jogginghose kommt oder nicht weil du
kannst du die schule auch mit
jogginghose gamespot kein ding so machen
wir uns auf viele macht das einfach das
ist cool
das volk ja ich habe schon wieder das
gefühl das video ist schon viel zu lange
ich könnte jetzt noch mehr dinge
aufzählen aber ich belasse es jetzt
erstmal hierbei auf jeden fall wenn euch
das video gefallen hat wirkt sich
natürlich sehr freuen wenn ihr noch nach
oben gehen soll und so war es eben
eigentliches website et cetera
ja und ich würde sagen hier auf der
rechten seite geht's weiter mit dem
ersten teil hiervon check das auf jeden
fall ab wenn ihr halt noch mehr sehen
wollt abonnieren die verkennt noch mit
dem motto wiederhole